yes
yes i understand completely
we'll absolutely be able to help you out
with that
i guarantee you
[Music]
oh
you must be talking about yagami
absolutely
we appreciate any interest you might
have
but it's just
wow
you know
must be so
nice to be a rock star
right salary chan
gandala sorry speaking
yes
yoga me is currently employed by our
firm
same [__] all
day
i guess everyone wants a lawyer who can
win huh
yagami sensei
hey throw me a bone
i never would have won without a hand
from these two
of course you wouldn't have
99 of these cases end up in convictions
it makes an acquittal a big deal even if
it was just luck
talk about a lawyer being a hero
makes even a former gangster look good i
guess so
wipe that grin off your face you think
you're better than us
i'm no saint
shh
could have fooled me
you know
you're not gonna win all of them
trust me val my record's not
are you listening of course i get the
message
well
shintani's available right now yeah you
bet
he's more experienced
are you hearing that
now i'm getting tossed your goddamn
leftovers
shut up man
okay
and you're sure he's as skilled as they
come trust me
but well that just can't be right
he hasn't won any cases you know how
rare that is
haven't you heard 99.9
of criminal court cases and with the
defendant behind bars pretty ridiculous
right
what
well
you still want yoga me though
hey can it
yes
and you're absolutely sure
i understand
i'll tell him
who was that
another call for yugami sensei
big whoop
but the client is
shinpei okubo
huh
not sure i believe that
ogelbo is a free man now not anymore
he's been arrested for murder come on we
already proved he was innocent right
it's a new case
he's being processed right now
what they told me is that
he stabbed his girlfriend emmy to death
set the apartment on fire
okabo would never do that
stabbing emijon
i just don't understand it
alcabal
how could he
it's not safe for you here now everyone
[Music]
that day
my career as a lawyer died alongside
emichon
both murdered by shinpei okabo
[Music]
team
are you getting close yet
yep right by the don quixote
heading your way
now you just about see our man
yeah i got him
he doesn't have a clue huh
you're getting good at this almost like
a pro
wow thanks i always dreamed of being a
professional stalker not sure i'd call
it that
you gotta admit this is crazy though
a detective tailing another detective
you only see that [__] on tv
crazy or not
stay focused
all right i'll join up with you soon
okay
step aside old man
goddamn trash the [__] he said move
huh
the [__] are you doing what
you want to die [__] what the hell is
his problem
what's going on back there buddy
uh
looks like i need to teach these punks a
little lesson
need to
didn't you tell me to keep my head down
hey who you calling punks you homeless
piece of [__]
huh
sorry kaito
i'll see you soon okay
so much for being careful
get a load of him
man you seeing this [__]
okay
my boy's a movie star
how's that
you're a damn joke
let's do this thing
oh
ah
[Music]
yes
hello
[Music]
who are you
i'm all done
kaitasan
where's our guy going on his way towards
pink street
crowd's thinning out get your ass over
here got it
and make it quick
any minute now he's gonna figure out i'm
shadowing him
he's on to me good luck talk it's all
you now
really i need more time
just get your ass over here if we lose
him it's on you
oh that's just rude
[Music]
what
what the
found him
finally thought you were never going to
catch up man
sorry
[Music]
hey hey you
it's high time you pay all the rent you
owe
i just need a little longer okay
just one more week
another week i am done warning you yes i
assure you it better be
bye for now then
oh that was close
[Music]
ah someone call me
i've been paranoid
[Music]
he's heading for the champion district
oh great we're never gonna find him in
that maze
probably why he's going
there thankfully we can always follow
him from above
yeah
want to break out the pigeon
just try to head him off kaito-san and
be ready on it
oh and try not to get carried away
can't afford to get that thing fixed
again
yeah yeah just don't lose him
[Music]
he just ducked into an empty lot
kaito-san
dead end we follow him we blow our cover
what do you think he's doing in there
probably meeting someone he doesn't want
to be seen with
makes sense
pigeons up
can you see it
hold on
[Music]
wow
suspicious
[Music]
hey
there it is
hold on i'll send the feed to your phone
nice flying kaito son
keep it steady
you've been practicing
now's not a good time talk
gotta concentrate
there's another guy in there with him
so he is meeting someone
hey i know that guy
he's a bookie for horse races
trying to gamble his way to paying off
debts huh
because that always works
yeah well if they came all the way out
here just to meet
he must have the cash on him
we'll get what we need if we move now
you remember what we're doing here right
collecting the dip that detected
oh i get it this is our chance
just relax let me do my thing okay
you got it todd
don't [__] it up
nice night huh detective
huh
i hear the bookies in comrocho make some
pretty good deals
you win 10 more you lose 10 percent less
and make it sound so enticing maybe i
should get in on it
hey where are you going don't you need
your money
what the hell is this who are you
i'm here to get my clients money back
before you lose it on another horse
so they hired a thug to collect
should i be impressed you found me
a thug well that's not very nice
you and i are in the same business
you're a detective
afraid so
i hear you're pretty hard to get a hold
of that's why the people you owe came to
me
look i know you have the money on you
you can't get out of this just do us
both a favor and pay up don't put up a
fight
well you're right
i have the money
but look
i'll pay everything back after i went
big on this next race just wait okay
are you serious i didn't track you down
just so you could maybe next time
what
you got kidding me
[Music]
he's making a run for it i saw
where are you going little guy
damn it get back here
[Music]
won't get away
just
stay away from me
hold up
uh [__] off
you need to learn when to quit
shut up
i have it all figured out
i'll get the money
ah
[Music]
i'm not done yet
ah
[Music]
i don't get it
didn't you say you're a detective
what's your name
i never said i'd field any questions
[__]
it's yagami
take a good look now do you believe me
so
let's be civil here
just hand over the cash okay
150 grand sound good
back the [__] off
you running some kind of racket here
i'll sue you oh yeah
huh
you gonna sue
the [__] do you think you are
huh
hold on kaito's son who the hell
you're not a detective [__] you're
[__] yakuza oh yeah
guess you know what'll happen if you
don't pay up there
ease up kaito-san
i'm sure he doesn't want to piss you off
anymore
i said all right
listen here [__]
i'm gonna sue your ass into the goddamn
ground
you see this
you broke my [__] nose
don't be so melodramatic
i think we both know who threw the first
punch
oh no way i'm gonna let that slide
just you watch you'll see the court's
gonna
huh
but that's
a lawyer's badge
so you're not a detective
and you still want to sue
you know
you won't know what hit you
[Music]
come roacho
no better place for a night out
a neon city
but the brighter the lights
the darker the shadows
the whole town's run by the toughest
yakuza family out there
the tojo clan
and the deeper you dig
the more interesting things get
[Music]
more dangerous too
take this burglary ring
just a bunch of kids looking for kicks
word is they met on some sketchy website
never even seen each other's faces
as for the cops
they can't catch a single one
[Music]
the only thing anyone really cares about
in kamurocho these days though
is the murders
over three months three kansai yakuza
have turned up dead
most think it's the tojo clan making
some kind of power move in the ongoing
turf war
this one's missing its eyes too
that's not the only thing though
all three of them were missing their
eyes
it's in one little corner of this city
that i run a detective agency
i work alongside my partner kaito-san
funny enough
he's ex tojo
and
me i'm takayuki yagami
i used to be a lawyer
but i put that life behind me three
years ago
as for my badge
it's barely even a decoration at this
point
[Music]
you